authoritarianism that's the path that
we're going down now i mean it's okay
we've we've noticed a trend when you
look at places like north korea and
china and all that as well they didn't
happen overnight there was baby steps
you know if you just try
you know a country can't just turn
around and go we're just going to go
full authoritarian boys like that you'll
be right everybody would kick off
everyone would get angry and it's the
jordan peterson described it the best
way where the government will encroach
you know two inches and keep going until
people start to get really angry and
then it will stop then it will wait
until everyone comes down and then it
will encroach a little bit more till
they get angry and stop and they'll just
keep doing it and doing it and doing it
and we had it with a terrorism you know
the america get the patriot act you know
we had things like the sniper's charter
also for terrorism so for terrorism the
government gathering more and more power
and then you had uh basically diversity
and stuff like that or why would you be
against this you know the government
controlling what you can say and the
things you can write and the type of
ways you can express yourself but it's
in the name of diversity why would you
be against that racist
like that's it's basically it's not just
a case of the government doing but it's
one the government also has a bunch of
brainwashed useful idiots that are on
their side allowing the government to do
this and basically we're trying to point
out like do you not see the government
are using this as an excuse to grab more
power and that's what they're doing like
when was when was the last time apart
from like really really archaic like
when was the last time the government
got rid of a law
that gave a hell of a lot more power
like like even surveillance laws and all
that as well you know basically you're
you can be monitored constantly
and we were fine with it because we were
like all but it protects us from
terrorism
you know terrorism still happens doesn't
it so it's obviously not working that
way
and like you say i think a few years it
would be a few years ago now but one of
the first uses of this new terrorist
legislation they arrested the pension at
the labour party conference for shouting
at one of the ministers or something
like terrorism yeah
they used anti-terrorism legislation to
arrest like what terrorists in the world
yeah it's getting pretty mental but
listen one thing i wanted to ask you
because i think a lot of people wouldn't
know this yeah and you know when we had
a long chat that came up is actually the
impact of like you know you're joking
about it you know there's funny things
about it but also there was an impact on
you in terms of your employment your
work your life and i think a lot of
people wouldn't know that so maybe tell
us a little bit about that i was accused
of
i had jobs i was working in security but
then whenever i tried to get you know
security is a mixing match you just
usually get a text for your phone can
you do a shift whenever i tried to get
stable employment while doing security
on top of it basically i would
i would with some of them i tried to be
honest in the interview going i'm just
going to be real with you guys right now
never got a call back so then i tried to
keep it secret just so that i could get
a job and then in all the places i got
into you know after a week or so or in
one case on my first day
i got recognized people knew who i was
and just start with me straight out the
door gone and also basically because
because because of the nazi pug thing
you know that basically what would they
say to you they would turn around and
say oh i say i would do this to the
company it would do that to the company
even though
most of the companies that actually did
fire me got a lot more [ __ ] for firing
me
than they would have for like letting me
work there because people managed to
find out one of the security firms that
i worked for and my boss at the time he
loved it he would get angry calls
lately people going i can't believe you
hire him you've gotten actually working
for you and he would sit there and go
like that yeah what are you going to do
no i'm not fighting him in fact i'm
going to offer him extra shifts but
he loved it i miss him
but
yeah
it was just
so it was being unemployable as a case
of i'm just trying to keep the ball
rolling with my youtube and all that
because see after this is gone you know
what can i do there's no job there's no
place that well high on me another one
you know maybe after that i'll start
arguing in favor of the welfare state
[Laughter]
what's that space um but like so that's
why i'm trying to do what i do but i'm
still getting attacked for what i'm
doing and i'm sort of like am i
am i allowed to feed myself but you know
am i allowed to keep a roof over my head
like what do you want me to do that man
they keep going after me no matter what
area i go into it's a case of like okay
then we'll make an agreement i'll i'll
drop everything i'll stop being all free
speech i'll stop being all right-wing
and all that stuff and i'll just go and
get a normal job they won't they
wouldn't even let me have that
no so i'm kind of i'm kind of stuck in
what i'm doing and what what's it i mean
like we joke about it and it is funny
what you know and the ridiculousness and
all the rest of it but being called a
nazi it's a pretty pretty vicious thing
to do
it's white noise to me now it doesn't
the world has lost all meaning it's like
the mega effect when you hear the same
thing over and over again it starts to
just lose its meaning and enunciation
and everything i guess that's what it is
now people none of these people know
what our actual nazis are like even in
that chat i had with that gentleman
yesterday he didn't even know he he
thinks like so just for anyone doesn't
know you had a chat with a left-leaning
comedian that i helped fully set you up
left left leaning i think he was a
little bit more than leaning but yeah i
think he loves that but
he's flat on the left oh yeah
so left when he's hanging off the plane
but like he
he didn't know what it was either
basically he thinks that
wanting to uh
deport illegal immigrants but being
completely fine with the legal ones
being here
he thinks that's far right
and i was just no
not at all and obviously he thinks that
a not wanting to associate with gay
people as far away if you're calling for
the deaths of or banning of
homosexuality yeah that's not right yeah
that's far right
a lot of muslim countries do that
i'm just saying i thought you didn't
want to get us demonetized it's not it's
not it's it's not you it's yeah
i feel like you're breaking up with me
[Laughter]
but it's like that type of stuff as well
these the overland window has shifted so
much that even
being a libertarian
is considered far right like that's what
i would consider myself i have a lot of
libertarian values everyone's like
oh you know the government should have
seen sexuality and everything was like
however the government has no [ __ ]
say what is that the government's
business yeah that man like was oh we
need government recognition why it's not
your plans
i'm honestly you don't need you know
validation from the government i don't
give a [ __ ] what the government thinks
about me
you need to recognize my sexuality maybe
you're a little bit needy oh man
government's not stopping you for
sucking dick
i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] your mother
but on the whole being called the nazi
thing it's like amazing to us because we
do this show francis is probably more
left-leaning that i'm kind of somewhere
in the center
immigrant with the jewish heritage yeah
yeah yeah so obviously
no but people are calling us for far
right i've been called alt-right
fascist pro-fascist obviously so far
she's critical
they know your own mind so much better
than you crypto fascism yeah that sounds
like a really good board game
i use crypto authoritarian doesn't back
up them and they get really angry when
you use the you use their own language
back at them
so so for and all we do on the show is
we try to talk to different people and
we just let them say what say their
piece like we're done with you right
yeah we've tried to challenge you a
little bit we've tried to listen to you
we don't interrupt you we don't try and
pretend that you meant something that
you didn't mean or and that now is far
right yeah and it's like where do you go
from here this is the most
see the most progress that i have seen
comes from talking to people it comes
from talking to people because people
use my associations on me all the time
you spoke to tommy once
absolutely yeah like nearly a year ago
and all that but like hey oh you're in
ukraine you know nigel farage blah blah
blah
these associations are what i'm basing
my opinions of you on and i'm just like
well i hang out with communists i talk
to anarchists talk to like full-on
liberals social democrats and everybody
i'm like why
why are they getting ignored like i
speak to them too
so why are you not interested in them is
because i speak to everyone they only
get mad about the ones that you know
they like to be mad about these guys but
when you speak to someone that doesn't
suit their narrative they're not
interested because i've noticed that see
i've had people who've hated me outright
hated me but assuming i've approached
them and had a chat with them we talked
regularly now i'm not going to say their
names because they won't outright admit
that they talk to me
because basically they couldn't lose
their jobs and she'll i'll get or
they'll get [ __ ] for the from their own
side because it's sort of you know don't
don't hang out with the smelly kids
that's literally the mentality that it
is but see how and bringing people sort
of back from the extremes
like see going out and speaking to them
is what does that legacy
how many times have you seen nazis or
white supremacists you know get the
platform get fired from their jobs get
you know punched and all that has that
ever made any of them change their
opinion
no no no it hasn't but speaking to them
does because one of the fears that i've
identified in the far right is they
think even if they abandon their beliefs
society will still shun them they're
like i can't come back like a society
just like what you're talking about with
you yeah
society sees nazism as that [ __ ] don't
wash off like that that's forever
right but even though i thought we used
to like the nice stories of a guy that
was like i was in the kkk for years and
now i'm not and you know i'm i'm here
with my black wife and my wife's son
that's different stuff right like people
used to love those stories but yeah
yeah redemption is good you know when
you hear that i used to be an outright
racist i'm not anymore no i'm a good
productive member of society good
those are lovely stories that's
excellent but not anymore and it's like
the far right know this where some of
them go
i want to leave
but i'm not going to be accepted back
nobody wants me back and all they can do
is hang around with the far righters you
know getting further and further you
know but just becoming ideologues
because they're not hearing conflicting
opinions whereas if you hold out you
know the friendly hand invite them out
for a drink be nice to them and
basically make it clear them you know if
you abandon your beliefs and come back
to the late you know we will be here for
you and everything in that works that
works if you reach out to them and be
nice and that you'll get people go oh
he's asking you to be nice to nazis was
that well it works like come up with a
better one because you just beating them
up in the streets not [ __ ] working
that man so if anything my idea is more
effective so why are you booing me i'm
right
like that type of [ __ ] so
[Music]